muy buenas noches el momento de conocer
cuáles son las principales noticias en
materia económica en américa latina y en
el resto del mundo y es por eso que nos
acompaña por supuesto nuestra compañera
daniela blandón danny muy buenas noches
comenzamos con una de las noticias del
día no que tiene que ver con que la
unión europea y eeuu finalmente lograron
una tregua tras un conflicto que duró
cerca de 17 años verdad noticias del día
y del año seguramente santiago porque
mire este es uno de los conflictos
fiscales más largos que transmitan la
organización mundial del comercio y
comenzó como lo decía hace 17 años con
acusaciones de parte y parte de que sus
gigantes aeronáuticos boeing y hervás
estaban recibiendo subsidios ilegales
que afectaban a sus competidores el
conflicto llegó a tal punto que la
entonces administración de donald trump
decidió en 2019 imponer aranceles por
unos 7.500 millones de dólares anuales a
productos europeos que no tienen nada
que ver con el sector aeronáutico desde
quesos españoles hasta galletas alemanas
y vinos franceses pasando
por todo tipo de bienes la unión europea
hizo lo propio en noviembre pasado grabó
tabaco licores y otros productos
estadounidenses por 4 mil millones hasta
el momento se han pagado 3300 millones
de dólares de la vila en marzo se había
acordado una suspensión por cuatro meses
de ese cobro sin embargo los líderes de
eeuu un avión europea decidieron
extenderlo por cinco años continuamos
ahora conocían américa latina pero está
haciendo noticias por varios temas en
estos días y comenzó a recuperar su
economía es así bueno su producción
nacional por lo menos así lo dice porque
aumentó un 13,8 por ciento en los
primeros cuatro meses de 2021 según el
instituto nacional de estadística pero
sólo en abril el repunte fue mayor del
58 49 por ciento lo que demuestra que el
país se está recuperando lentamente de
la crisis ocasionada por el cob y 19
sólo el sector de la construcción tuvo
un aumento de casi el 1000 por ciento en
el cuarto mes pero falta mucho camino
por recorrer santiago el informe destaca
que la producción todavía no alcanza a
estar en niveles
veremos qué sucede en la nación
suramericana ahora naciones unidas hizo
un pedido bastante interesante no a los
gobiernos del mundo les pidió que
dirijan sus políticas de empleo a los
más vulnerables verdad sí señor en un
informe conjunto la comisión económica
para américa latina y el caribe y la
organización internacional del trabajo
ambas adscritas a la onu destacan que
esos sectores vulnerables de los que
usted hablas son los trabajadores
informales y las mujeres
la propuesta es entonces apostarle a la
formalización laboral ya la inclusión
femenina en el ámbito productivo también
dicen que hay que dirigir esfuerzos a
los sectores más golpeados como
hostelería construcción y comercio que
tuvieron en 2020 las tasas de desempleo
más altas vamos ahora con un tema
daniela el que le pusiste un título que
causa muchisima intriga y lo quiero leer
textualmente como perder 500 millones de
dólares en tan solo 15 segundos de qué
se trata esta noticia
santiago pues miren primero lo invito a
que veamos lo que sucedió el lunes en
una conferencia de prensa de la euros
[Música]
bueno pues analistas atribuyen ese gesto
de cristiano ronaldo la caída del 0,2
por ciento en el precio de las acciones
de coca-cola company que es uno de los
grandes patrocinadores de ese torneo
parece poco pero ese porcentaje equivale
a unos 500 millones de dólares
aproximadamente santiago y además
expresa la capitalización bursátil que
perdió la multinacional en el día de hoy
y como los publicistas de las grandes
marcas no se quedan con nada la cadena
de restaurantes kfc aprovechó este trino
en el que un usuario criticaron al dow
por animar a la gente a beber agua al
tiempo que promociona grandes baldes de
pollo frito respondió que sí que es
verdad que todo el mundo sabe que a
cristiano ronaldo le va muy bien con las
alas de pollo y eso a pesar de que la
estrella del juventus se ha ganado la
reputación de ser un futbolista casi
obsesionado con la vida fit increíble el
poder también de una persona no con tan
sólo un gesto llevarle estos problemas
al gigante indicadores de la jornada ni
wall street y cerró en rojo pendiente
todavía de los resultados de la reunión
mensual de la reserva federal
este miércoles en europa la bolsa de
londres marcó su mejor nivel en 16 meses
y la cautela se impuso en los mercados
de américa latina que tuvieron leves
variaciones muchísimas gracias daniel
hablando por otra completísima crónica
económica en esta audiencia limitamos a
seguir informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación regresamos en
minutos